surround your mangos greatness what's up
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe that you have the
ability to do something special that
will change the planet instead of help
you on your journey today we're going to
learn how to surround yourself with
greatness you will move in the direction
of the people that you associate with so
I it's important to associate with
people that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you choose and and you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll move in that direction and the
most important person by far in that
respect is your spouse I can't
overemphasize how important that is your
right the friends you have they will
form you as you go through life and make
some good friends keep them for the rest
of your life but have them be people
that you admire as well as Wykeham how
can you help the human race how can you
help the human race the human species
progress
I'm not joking either this is something
I think we all have to be aware of at
the end of the day the human animal is a
social animal and our very survival
depends on our ability to form
communities to form cultures what's a
community what's a culture it's a group
of people with a common set of values
and beliefs right what's a country it's
a group of people with a common set of
values and beliefs
what's a company it should be a group of
people with a common set of values and
beliefs when we're surrounded by people
who believe what we believe something
remarkable happens Trust emerges and
make no mistake of it trust as a feeling
a distinctly human feeling you know we
all have friends we're total screw-ups
and yet we still trust them right
Trust is not a check with simply doing
everything you say you're going to do
doesn't that much does not mean people
will inherently trust you it just means
you're reliable
we need trust right we need trust when
we're surrounded by people who believe
what we believe and Trust starts to
emerge and we trust them and they trust
us we're more willing to take risks
we're more willing to experiment which
requires failure we're more willing to
explore and go somewhere with that no
one has ever gone before
with the confidence that if we fail if
we trip over if we turn our backs that
those within our community those who we
trust and who trust us will look after
us while we're gone will pick us up when
we fall over will help us when we're
hurt our very survival depends on it
we're not good at everything we're not
good by ourselves you know if I send you
out to go fight a saber-toothed tiger by
yourself odds are Tiger one you zero
it's not gonna go very well but if you
go out as a group we're pretty damn
amazing and the reason is is because we
all have our strengths and we all of our
certain weaknesses and the goal is not
to fix your weaknesses the goal is to
amplify your strengths and surround
yourself with the people who can do what
you can't do but it's not just based on
skills and and application and
experience it's based on what you
believe it's based on what you believe
you see simply being good at something
and having somebody else being good what
you're no good at does not mean you will
trust each other trust the sense of
trust comes from the sense of common
values and common beliefs that improve
it how many of you from New York okay
bunch of you are you friends with
everybody in New York why not why not
but when you go to Los Angeles and you
meet someone from New York you're like
hey I'm from New York and you're best
friends right and when you go to France
you there you are in the Paris metro
minding your own business and you're
here in American accent behind you and
you turn around and say hey where're you
from
they say Los Angeles you like hey I'm
from New York and you're best friends
because when you're surrounded by people
who don't believe what you believe when
you're in a strange environment where
you don't feel comfortable you look for
anyone who may share some of
same values and beliefs that you have
and you start to form a very wheat real
and very intense bond with them simply
because you know that they have a basic
understanding of how you grow up of the
things that you care about of the life
that you live back home well the same is
true when we go to work do we want to go
to work with people who understand us
who believe what we believe who have a
similar view of the world that has
nothing to do with their opinions and
the differences that we share
that's good that's called diversity
that's called advantages to
problem-solving which is we can all look
at the same thing from a different angle
and come up with solutions what I'm
talking about is why should you help
each other in the first place
what are you in pursuit of now the
question is is what creates that sense
of values and beliefs what creates that
sense of trust right are very human
instinct we know how to find people who
believe what we believe our survival
depends on it we're biologically gifted
with this idea if I ask you to go out in
the street and find all the people who
believe what you believe you know
exactly what to do
you're gonna strike up conversations
you're gonna start talking to people and
you either you'll have a good feeling
about them or you won't either you'll
have chemistry whatever that means or
you don't
sometimes it's quick sometimes it's slow
but we know how to do it it's called
making friends it's called dating it's
called networking we have the innate
ability to do it
what did you get that that business says
because you you surpassed everybody in
in boxing and sports and everything in
general I'm watching you it's like you
bigger than an NFL franchise it's just
what's he me believe it you know I'm
gonna be honest me and a lot of my guys
a lot of my say I have a team also but
you know my team don't get in there and
go to war like I go to war but they go
to war on the outside I didn't go to war
I'm very very tough on my team I want my
team to be the best that they can be on
the outside and but as far as on the
outside you know al Heyman
that's all jela SOG a legend a legend a
very shrewd business
man learner ellaby that master degree oh
you know in business so you know when
you surround yourself with people like
this just just being around certain
individual searches certain individuals
like even been around Don King been
around Bob Arum
being around just different people
that's been in the game a long time and
and you know my being there buddies you
know every time I got around my being
there buddies I was more like it's cool
to come over your house but I need a
house like this yeah it's cool to ride
on your yacht but I needed yacht like
this is cool around on your jet but I
wanted to get like patches and I said no
I don't want to ride on yours you showed
me how to get it oh you can't be my
friend if you can't show me how to get
it pleaseth once they showed me how to
get it in I can install it in my
children then it goes it goes it drives
down
it's a bloodline class so it's about
wealth you know I'm no longer rich and
wealthy why you know what gives me
strength all the time is to be able to
have formulated a group of people around
me that are my friends and my family you
know those two words are meshed in my
opinion but it's given me a grounding
that as insane as my life can be
sometimes is always refreshing and
they're always so honest with me and I'm
so thankful for that
everybody's successful a is a blue for
now you laid a blueprint out uh you know
I can go down a list from comedians to
actors to entrepreneurs to self-made
moguls you look at Russell Simmons you
look at jay-z
you look at Tyler Perry you look at puff
I mean you're looking at people to start
off with a small vision and that vision
manifested into something beyond
expectation so what I did was from the
people around me my mentors Eddie Murphy
Chris Rock Pryor who are all on the wall
all in walls yeah all oh no so you
surround yourself with I surround myself
with a constant reminder of who is great
constantly I come down these steps every
day I look at Richard oh he's great I
see Eddie he was great I see Chris Rock
he was great it's a constant reminder
what am I trying to achieve I want to be
great so that motivates me so much
thinking separates me is my drive my
drive is other people's success but does
that look like your hoop
now it doesn't look like your group I
mean in no way shape manner or form you
know maybe if we had a bunch of bunny
rabbits running there or it's
unbelievable but again you are who you
hang around with you know and as Oprah
Winfrey says and which I talk about a
lot is that you want people with a like
mind and that are better than you
smarter than you more intelligent than
you to get on your bus and don't be so
concerned about what you're gonna do
with those people but you want to you
know the joint brain is you know there's
nothing the joint brain collective brain
or brains can't overcome and I give the
example of the atomic bomb the Manhattan
Project and they were put together and
they were told we need we need to
develop a weapon of mass destruction
which they didn't call it that back in
those days in the middle 40s to end the
war in the Pacific
and they did they didn't know if it was
implode or explode but they did but if
your if your team doesn't look like that
then you should I won't say you should
give serious thought you should just
change right now I'm standing in the
middle of my library this is my favorite
place you know Earl and you know see if
you surround your mind with greatness
some of us gonna rub off well the hope
wait some of it has rubbed off on me I
have maybe three or four thousand books
here on the Shelf they're all in
alphabetical order by author they're all
catalogued so I know where to find
something just like that I go by authors
more than the title of the book do you
know that when I started studying these
books I really didn't know very much
about anything I had two months high
school I was 26 years old a bad work
record a bad attitude and and virtually
no experience and you know in a
relatively short period of time my
income went from four thousand one
hundred and seventy five thousand a year
then we're over a million the most
important is tourists what I like to
call surround yourself with with your
dream team hmm I called my Josh Altman's
dream team and it consists of a good
amount of support from people that I
trust
value their opinion and who I surround
myself with I always say that you are
the average of five people that you
surround yourselves with right you ever
hear that before
yeah totally jim rome just made that up
right so I think it's super super
important to do that so in real estate
for example I have the best mortgage
broker who's available 24/7 for me and
we've worked our way up in the business
together I have you know everybody from
the best title guy and escrow guy and
and all that so I surround myself with
this team of people who I can trust and
they can guide me in the right
directions of whatever I do so that's
one way obviously in any business is
just surround yourself with some with
people who support you how do you stay
grounded how do you do it well I got a
get a wife that kicks my first of all
kids that tell it like it is you know
that to me is love right there when your
kids you know dad you're being a jerk
you know yeah I love that that that's
what helps me a lot
family certainly does that I think the
guys in the band too we all keep each
other in check
like it you know dude is that limo a
little too long come on I mean you know
just goofy things like that you know we
we try and keep each other real so I
think not surrounding ourselves with yes
men too which can really just totally
distort your reality right now you can
do anything you can be anything and yes
obstacles will come along but once again
we are living in a whole new world some
people are making a living of just
making videos
one of my favorite youtubers jenna
Marbles genius just a short video every
single week but she's creating abundance
what about Michelle Phan write makeup
she started way back in the day but now
she's created something for herself and
once again there's there's always gonna
be obstacles right this ain't Paradise
Island out here right you're in the
jungle in the jungle you don't know what
to expect there's all kinds of creatures
so you gotta ask yourself am i
surrounding myself with people that
actually are encouraging me to follow my
vision and my dream or am i surrounded
myself with what Danny West cools these
are the dream killers right thank you
guys so much for watching I'd love to
know what did you think what was the
clip that resonated the most with you
what was the most important lesson that
you learned and how are you going to
apply it to your life into your business
I love to hear thoughts if you want to
leave a comment down below I also want
to give a quick shout out to Christina
and Sam woo my video editing team thank
you guys so much for picking up copy of
my book and sharing it on Twitter I
really appreciate the support guys and
I'm so glad you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon